here's the kicker you know what's crazy
about lying
half the battle with line is you're
trying to avoid conflict
yes you're trying to avoid conflict are
you trying to avoid uh uh
embarrassment or you wanna look cooler
you know you know the whole thing where
guys will say they've been with three
times the girls they've been with and
girls will say
three times less than the guys they've
really been we ever heard that story
before
scientists have done extensive research
on this so don't call me out and say pat
had a
you know moment where he's calling out
women but
why do men say three times because they
want to be three times cooler
why do women say three times less
because they want to be embarrassed
less right to say well i haven't really
gone in full run as much as i have okay
so that's not going away just so you
know that now there's a difference
between that
and lies like that or
you have a commitment to hit you don't
hit it that's a problem
okay that's a problem there's a
difference between that
and you know
a compliance lie you can you can take a
company down with a compliance slide
there's a difference between that and
but i call out the behavior
because i don't tolerate the behavior i
don't tolerate manipulative behavior
i don't tolerate games and i don't
tolerate anything that's going to hurt
the company
and bring others down so the more you
talk about it sometimes
the challenge of assignment is your
values and principles to the field
or your employees or your executive team
is not clear
if they don't know your set of values
and principles and you don't
talk about it over and over and over and
over and over and over again
then they don't know what your
expectations are right they're kind of
like
i don't know what it takes to make simon
happy i don't know what's a good
employee
i don't know what's a good partner i
don't know what's a good executive
i don't know what's a good investor
because you've never had those values
and principles so how do you do that
well you take a piece of paper and a
sunday afternoon or saturday afternoon
and you sit down and say what are the
best
employees i've ever had make a list of
what made them the best
what do you love most about johnny
jackie larry mary
and then who were the employees
or what kind of behavior hurt the
company the most and what set back the
company the most
okay what were those behaviors which one
of those behaviors will you not tolerate
great then guess what go tell the
stories
what i give them specific names go tell
the stories
then i'm going to sit there and i'm
going to say oh
i do that sometimes okay i got to work
on that
oh i do that sometimes he likes that
awesome i got a shot here
oh phenomenal he loves that that's me
he's talking about me i don't think this
company is for me i gotta go
it's okay it's okay
but you gotta share your values and
principles i read a book a few months
ago called no rules rules and i had
every one of my employees read the book
norah's rules and i had them read what
measure what matters
and after everybody read no rules rules
we kind of sat down and we went through
the process of what everybody was saying
what i was saying
kind of figured out some people just
don't belong here in the culture and i'm
not changing
i'm not changing because if i have to
conform to you i never had a real
culture
i didn't take time to really process
what my culture was
the moment you do that then they'll know
what to respond to but if they don't you
keep it a secret
no one knows what's bothering and what's
not and by the way
if i lose safe around you and you want
me to be around with you long term
if you don't allow me to save face i
will leave you because you offended me
so you you also got to make sure you're
not
you know hey papa you know you're not
coming out just like
i don't care what happens you know now
you don't want to do that you got to let
me save face because i'm going to make
more mistakes
you know if i don't have that
opportunity for people to say face
sometimes you need a crisis to
get create even more loyalty with your
employees i don't know if this makes
sense
sometimes you need a problem where we
overcome together
then the team's like this that's why so
many people when they go to war together
their level of bond is
the kind that they'll never have with
their wives or husbands or you know
kids it's different we went to work
together we almost died together
we were so annoyed with each other
because somebody screwed up but we
overcame that
when we came back safe and we saved
lives you have to give that opportunity
for people as well
work you on yourself on a leader make a
note of what you want tolerate what you
like
what's been qualities of your best
employees give that message to your guys
then go talk to that person help them
save face and help them save their ego
and then challenge them to improve and
then go about your business
so you just got a sneak little peek from
an episode that i did in this video if
you want to see the full episode click
over here to watch the entire episode
and if you've not subscribed
to this channel please do so take care
everybody
[Music]